Salut aujourd'hui
on est mercredi ,  c'est donc le jour des astuces de la  semaine !
Je suis toujours chez Tao et on a eu une grande discussion hier soir
entre mec et tout...
on parlais... parlais...
Tu peux être mentaliste, chinois tu peux être ce que tu veux...
tu mets 2 mecs ensemble
ça parle de fille... et comme la femme de Tao était là
on a aussi parlé des relations hommes-femmes
et je me suis dit : "C'est très bien, c'est un bon sujet
pour mon thème du mercredi."
Aujourd'hui je vous donne 4 astuces pour savoir si vous plaisez à quelqu'un.
En plus de ça, ça fait quand même pas mal de temps dans les commentaires que vous me demandez
des astuces sur ce sujet là.
Il y a aussi des astuces de drague, je ferai une vidéo plus tard là dessus, enfin du moins j'essayerai de le faire.
Je sais pas si je suis très compétent en la matière.
Je pense pas d'ailleurs. Mais ça n'empêche pas d'essayer d'en parler.
Je vous précise c'est pas des astuces pour draguer, c'est des astuces pour voir si l'autre est réceptif
Est ce qu'on plait à quelqu'un ? Et ce qu'on intéresse une personne ?
Est ce qu'on va se prendre un râteau ?!
On aime pas prendre des râteaux .
Astuce numéro une : le regard.
Vous devez regarder le regard de la personne.
Quand on plaît à quelqu'un
on se rend compte que les regards sont plus appuyés,
ils sont plus insitants, ils sont plus longs.
La personne nous regarde plus souvent, elle cherche un petit peu nos yeux
beaucoup plus que dans une conversation normale
Et si vous avez l'occasion, encore une fois
la pupille en dit long : plus la pupille est dilatée,  plus la personne est intéressée par vous.
C'est un signe d’intéressement, c'est un signe d'excitation la dilation de la pupille
sans croire que vous excitez l'autre.
En tout cas la personne vous trouve attirante
ce qui est plutôt bon signe.
Astuce numéro 2 : le ton de la voix qu'utilise la personne qui vous parle
que ce soit un homme ou une femme encore une fois
ça marche pour les deux.
Homme à femme, femme à homme, homme homme, femme femme.
On utilise une voix différente avec la personne qu'on a envie de charmer
ou une personne qui nous plaît. Ou une personne avec qui on est en couple.
- T'as besoin d'un coup de main ? Ça va ? Tout va bien ? Tu me dis hein !
Jamais on parle comme ça dans la réalité ! Jamais on parle comme ça à ses potes !
Il y a qu'avec la personne avec qui qu'on est en couple quon parle comme ça.
Et de la même manière, la personne qui nous intéresse, une personne qui nous plaît
on lui parle un petit peu différemment.
Donc observez comment la personne parle aux autres et comment elle vous parle à vous !
Essayez de voir si elle prend une voix plus aiguë, une voix plus douce, une voix plus charmante, une voix de .. lover.
-Voix au loin, aiguë- Tu m'aide s'il te plaît ? (RIRE)
La vraie astuce, c'est vraiment de comparer comment la personne parle aux autres et comment elle vous parle à vous !
Troisième astuce : le contact physique
Et on se touche, et on se cherche ... Enfin on se touche ! On se détend quand même
On ... On se touche comme ça quoi.
On tape sur le bras pour dire une blague..
Une personne à qui vous plaisez va chercher plus de contacts
Et j'suis sûr que vous aussi, quand quelqu'un vous plaît
vous cherchez plus de contacts physique, des petits rapprochements.
C'est pas grand chose, mais c'est plus fréquent que la normale.
Alors attention quand même a pas se faire des films !
Il y a des personnes qui sont très très tactiles, tout le temps, avec tout le monde.
Mais dans le jeu de la séduction et de l'attirance
On cherche quand même le moindre prétexte pour se rapprocher de l'autre
pour toucher un petit peu l'autre, pour
créer des espèces de connexions  des sortes de connexions comme ça
Et si vous, vous souhaitez savoir si vous plaisez à une personne
vous pouvez essayer
de faire vous ce genre de contact
ce genre de rapprochement
encore une fois sans exagérer
vous pouvez jauger de sa réaction si c'est plutot positif, négatif
si la personne cherche a fuir ce contact
gentiment élégamment ou pas
ou si au contraire elle y réponds de la même manière
ça vous donne une bonne piste
4ième et dernière astuce
ça rejoint un petit peu ce que j'ai dit précédemment
il faut absolument que vous analysiez cette personne
dans sa relation avec les autres
et avec les autres avec qui elle a le même type de rapport
c'est à dire pas forcément avec ses amis
mais avec des gens qu'elle connais au même niveau que vous
si cette personne ne vous connais pas regardez comment elle est avec les personnes qu'elle ne connais pas non plus
ça vous évitera t’interprétait  maladroitement des signes de politesse ou des signes de gentillesse
le gros problème qu'on soit un mec ou une femme c'est de se faire un film
et de croire que la personne est intéressée par nous
alors que c'est une personne sympathique,
une personne gentille,
une personne avenante
ça permet aussi de détecter dans certains cas si c'est quelqu'un
qui drague tout le monde dans cette soirée
après ça peut vous intéresser
mais il n'y a rien de tel que le comparatif
ne vous focalisez pas complètement sur votre relation sur vos échanges avec la personne en question
Comparer vraiment vos moments avec elle, avec les moments qu'elle a avec les autres personnes
Voilà c'était quelques astuces du cœur aujourd'hui en ce mercredi
C'est la première fois que je traite un peu de sujet alors j'ai fait un petit peu court
mais on y reviendra si ça vous intéresse vous avez juste à me le dire dans les commentaires
et puis vous me le faite savoir en laissant un petit pouce en l'air
merci d'avoir regarder cette vidéo.
N'oubliez pas que demain je fais la FAQ SnapChat j'ouvrirai vos SnapChat
vous avez encore jusqu'à 19h pour m'envoyer un Snap avec votre question
avec une photo, avec ce que vous voulez
ce qui vous fait marrer
N'oubliez pas non plus de vous abonnez
parce que c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc RDV demain à 17h pour le prochain mental vlog
tchao